over the weekend at the ACMs Keith Urban
revealed this exciting scoop to ET about
his new album ripcord carries on the
record to Aranda was on there as well so
when we spoke with the country star on
Wednesday at part 1 of the American Idol
finale we had to get more details on the
exciting collaboration together yeah I
wrote a song with this guy called Busby
the song's called the fighter it's a I
would say kind of a : response to song -
and a guy and a girl and carries on that
song with me you keep hinting that
there's gonna be a collaboration
tomorrow and I'm singing tomorrow night
- yeah I'm actually a song with somebody
who I toured with many years ago and
it'll be a song that everybody knows and
that's all I can say the singers lips
might be sealed about any finale
surprises but he had no hesitation when
it came to praising both remaining Idol
contestants Lepore sure Renee Ian Trent
Harmon it's gonna be interesting to see
what at mr. Moana I'm sure whoever wins
it it won't be a landslide because it's
a I mean the two incredible singers